der Staat hat die Pflicht seine
Bürgerinnen und Bürger vor Gefahren zu
schützen wie weit ist der in der
corona-pandemie gegangen war er
übergriffig
im Namen des Volkes die Regelungen über
das Verlassen der eigenen Wohnung waren
mit dem Grundsatz der
Verhältnismäßigkeit nicht vereinbar
gemeint ist die bayerische
Ausgangssperre im ersten pandemia
rechtswidrig der Staat als Schutzmacht
oder doch ein Fremder im eigenen Land
wir müssen lernen was ist bei unseren
Institutionen schief gelaufen warum
haben Institutionen während der Pandemie
versagt und ihre Aufgabe nicht erfüllt
und wir müssen daran arbeiten die Gräben
in der Gesellschaft wieder zuzuschütten
letztlich um es ein bisschen um es auf
den Punkt zu bringen wir müssen die
Gesellschaft wieder versöhnen es gab das
einsame sterben alter Menschen es gibt
viele tiefe Wunden es gab den Versuch
der Aufklärung der erste Lockdown
unstrittig sagt ein Expertengremium im
Sommer ansonsten das nüchterne Ergebnis
insgesamt ist ein Zusammenhang zwischen
der Höhe der Inzidenz und der
maßnahmenstärke nicht erkennbar und
kontroverse Meinungen dürfen nicht
ausgeklammert werden
der Deutsche Ethikrat zeigt sich
inzwischen selbstkritisch zu spät zu
wenig habe man etwa auf die Bedürfnisse
von Kindern und Jugendlichen geschaut
Zeit für eine Entschuldigung
das werden wir und werde ich im Moment
ständig gefragt dass mit diesem
entschuldigen da würde ich gerne was
prinzipielles dazu sagen
da steckt ja dahinter man wäre schuldig
geworden und ich glaube das ist ganz
wichtig dass man das einmal
unterstreicht darum geht es nicht darum
geht es nicht doch die Schuldfrage wird
durchaus gestellt man hat Kinder als als
superspredder bezeichnet als Verteiler
der Infektionskrankheiten das sind sie
nachweislich nie gewesen und insofern
sind Kinder hier missbraucht worden für
für politische Zwecke sie sind teilweise
nicht gesehen worden und das kann man
schon der Politik der Gesundheitspolitik
in Deutschland vorwerfen der
Bundesgesundheitsminister muss Anfang
November einen großen Fehler in der
corona-politik eingestehen nach dem
Wissen von heute kommt man klar zu der
Erkenntnis dass die Kita Schließungen zu
Beginn der Pandemie nicht nötig gewesen
wären kein Wort des Bedauerns lauterbach
sich der virusbekämpfung verschrieben
und den möglichen Spätfolgen bilon kobit
Probleme etwa mit Impfungen lange Zeit
kein Thema
Impfungen sind hat mehr oder weniger
nebenwirkungsfrei das muss immer wieder
gesagt werden das ist also das sind die
Leute die sich jetzt nicht impfen lassen
wollen das sind ja auch zum Teil Opfer
der schäbigen Desinformationen in den
sozialen Medien gewesen das ist auch
schwere Nebenwirkungen gibt mittlerweile
Konsens Gesellschaft gespalten in einem
Mehrheit der Impfbefürworter und eine
Minderheit der Gegner oder skeptika
sprechen ja nicht darüber über eine
kleine Gruppe sondern wir sprechen
Gruppe für die ungefähr 20 Millionen
Menschen umfassen diesem Land und die
Demokratie muss sich immer auch im
Krisensituationen daran messen lassen
wie sie mit ihnen Minderheiten umgeht
braucht es den schonungslosen Rückblick
auf die corona-politik wie er immer
wieder gefordert wird ich glaube jetzt
nachträglich ein Gremium einzusetzen was
ich losgekoppelt von allen anderen
dringenden Reformen Diskursen die wir in
der Politik haben auch mit der Pandemie
noch beschäftigen wird ich glaube es
bringt uns nicht wirklich weiter also
ich glaube man sollte nicht in diese
Überheblichkeit reinrutschen und sagen
man ist fehlerfrei jeder Mensch ist hat
mein Fehler gemacht und macht auch
Fehler das ist in der Natur der Sache
und hier sollen wir so gut wie möglich
das Beste erreichen und auch eine
Fehlerkultur leben fast drei Jahre
Pandemie viele offene Wunden von
grundsätzlicher politischer Fehlerkultur
kann aber nicht die Rede sein
und im Studio begrüße ich jetzt den Mann
der von sich selbst sagt dass ihm Corona
zumindest geholfen habe
Gesundheitsminister zu werden guten
Abend Karl Lauterbach guten Abend
ihr Koalitionspartner FDP fordert wir
haben es gerade gehört eine Fehlerkultur
was war denn ihr größter Fehler in
dieser Pandemie
also das würde ich selbst für mich nicht
bewerten wollen das müssen andere machen
ich glaube wir haben in Beitrag eben
gesehen habe vielleicht hier ein
falschen Eindruck bekommen natürlich hat
jeder Fehler gemacht mein Vorgänger ich
selbst wir als Gruppe aber muss
unterscheiden zwischen einem Fehler und
einem neuen wissen zum Beispiel dass die
Kinder keine Superstar sind das wissen
wir heute das wusste man damals aber
nicht so genau da muss man das auch
einräumen da habe ich ja gesagt aus der
Sicht von heute war das ein Fehler das
ist aber das gehört dazu das muss also
bedacht werden aber wir dürfen folgenden
wichtigen Fehler nicht machen wir haben
ja relativ strenge Regeln gehabt die
haben auch etwas gebracht wir haben im
Vergleich zu anderen europäischen
Ländern um uns herum eine niedrige
Sterblichkeit gehabt und zwar in allen
Altersgruppen das ist auch eine Erfolg
es gab nicht nur Fehler selbst wenn es
jetzt nachträgliches wissen oder
Erkenntnis es wären dann nicht
Entschuldigung sein ist der Politik
angemessen es kommt darauf an was es hat
ist ich kann mich also hier nicht
entschuld bisschen für Dinge die quasi
von meinen Vorgängern zu vertreten sind
ich muss aber ehrlich sein was wissen
wir heute ich muss heute zum Beispiel
klar sagen mit dem Wissen von heute
waren die kita-schließungen nicht
notwendig hat man das Wissen früher
gehabt da ist die Antwort nein der
damals haben die wichtigsten Berater der
Bundesregierung allesamt zur Schließung
geraten nun fordert jetzt Wolfgang
Kubicki immerhin Vizepräsident des
Deutschen Bundestags eine
onkett-kommission würden sie sich dem
Anschließen ich möchte ja die Vorschläge
von Herrn Kubicki nicht kommentieren
mein ich glaube dass das vom Parlament
zu beschließen ist dass heute nicht der
Minister machen da geht es ja auch um
die Arbeit der Regierung und wenn die
also wenn das Parlament beispielsweise
hier die Vorschläge aufgreift und
kontrolliert das noch anders fände ich
das nicht falsch also wir haben aus
meiner Sicht da nicht so verbergen und
aufklärung ist wichtig aber wie gesagt
wogegen ich mich wäre ist der Eindruck
unsere Sozialpolitik die war ja strenger
als in anderen Ländern wäre gescheitert
wir haben viel geopfert ich bedanke mich
bei allen Eltern und auch bei all
denjenigen die Opfer gebracht haben aber
wir haben auch eine geringere
Sterblichkeit gehabt die aus das war ja
auch unser Ziel wir haben eine alte
Bevölkerung und eine große influe gerade
in den neuen Bundesländern diese Leute
haben wir geschützt du lässt Bayern seit
gestern auch wieder die Maske fallen im
öffentlichen Nahverkehr wurden da aus
ihrer Sicht die falschen Lehren gezogen
ja auf jeden Fall denn die Krankenhäuser
sind ja voll die Kinder müssen geschützt
werden wir haben derzeit zu wenig
Personal in allen Krankenhäusern das
heißt ich hätte mir gewünscht dass man
hier einfach hingeht und sagt in der
Lage wo das Personal überlastet ist wo
die Kinder nicht unterkommen das sind
wir Erwachsenen so vernünftig und tragen
Maske um die Kinder zu schützen und da
hätte ich es von der bayerischen
Regierung auch nicht falsch gefunden
wenn man da gesagt hätte wir probieren
uns jetzt mal nicht als die oberlockerer
der Regierung also wir sind die Ersten
die alles aufmachen sondern sondern wenn
man hier Solidarität mit den Kindern
gezeigt hätte und mit denjenigen die
jetzt in der Klinik arbeiten auch über
die Feiertage das hätte mir mehr
imponiert sie haben vom sogenannten
letzten großen Gefecht in diesem Winter
gesprochen gegen Corona das heißt wir
sind danach im Wesentlichen durch ich
glaube dass das Virus sich in einer
Sackgasse mutiert hat das wäre jetzt
kompliziert zu erläutern aber die
Varianten die wir jetzt sehen die haben
alle eines gemeinsam die sind sehr
ansteckend aber nicht mehr so gefährlich
wie die ursprünglichen Varianten daher
glaube ich dass wir im nächsten Jahr da
tatsächlich eine wesentliche Entlastung
zu sehen haben ob das dann auf Dauer so
bleibt weiß man nicht aber ich glaube
dass wir wirklich im nächsten Jahr eine
deutliche Verbesserung erwarten können
daher appelliere ich auch noch mal an
alle die auch die jetzt zuhören die
letzten Wochen die letzten Monate wo wir
uns gegenseitig schützen können auch
über die Feiertage bitte sind sie
vorsichtig nehmen sie das ernst und
jetzt haben wir so lange
zusammengestanden jetzt die Solidarität
noch haben die
Sachverständigenkommission hat ja die
schlechte Datenlage bei Corona
stabilisiert haben sie das eigentlich
verbessert wir arbeiten daran wir haben
den pandemerada gemacht aber wir müssen
weitergehen ich war ja jetzt in Boston
an der HAVAG Uni haben wir eine
Kooperation ins Auge gefasst da wollen
wir eine große Konferenz in Deutschland
machen wir sind beim Thema Datennutzung
10 Jahre zurück das ist einfach
unakzeptabel Krankenhaus und also
Digitalisierung werden Schwerpunkte
meiner Arbeit in den nächsten Jahren
sein eine große Konferenz USA
Gedanke also derzeit können die
europäischen Daten nicht in Amerika
genutzt werden und umgekehrt und die
deutschen Daten sind noch nichtmals da
und da ist der Gedanke eine große
Konferenz Experten der hafer-universität
der Regierung EU-Experten unsere besten
Leute dass wir uns auf einen gemeinsamen
Standard für einigen denn sonst kommen
wir nicht weiter die Daten sprechen
nicht miteinander Herr Minister
herzlichen Dank für das Gespräch danke
Ihnen